how did you hear about this
uh through a friend oh i'm a huge fan of
this series
do you have any advice for anybody else
to play never do it if your dad
happens to be a billionaire let's say
the wealthiest person to
ever exist in history don't mention that
in the first round
okay but do like any of you need a
thousand dollars
like i i have a card that says son of
jeff bezos and i just show that
to people and i'm allowed to do anything
how do you feel about today
it was hard today uh people are mean
okay how about instead of arguing
and getting into the details about how
much money my dad makes
how about we physically fight each other
yes very much so you know when i get
attacked i get very mean
i just want to apologize to the other
people in the group
i'm sorry that i yelled i am the money
god about before me
that was in bad taste i'm sorry that i
vowed i would tell my dad to cancel all
future seasons of fleabag i don't know
what i was thinking there i like
i like fleabag i don't know why i would
do that i'm sorry that i told each
contestant i would uncle bend them
which is when you murder someone in
their family who is old and wise and
offers a lot of great advice
a la uncle ben in the spider-man movies
i'm sorry that when everyone talked
about their really sad
struggles i yelled boring and
wrap it up i didn't actually enjoy this
experience at all